you've said that uh lard Cohen is uh a
songwriting inspiration of
yours I saw you perform his song Chelsea
Hotel brilliantly on the
internet um it's about for people who
don't know his uh his love affair with
uh Janet
Joplin how's that song make you feel
great I love that song which aspect
musically The Melancholy feeling the
hopeful
feeling the the the cocky feeling all of
it like every single line has a
different feeling to it really yeah but
as a whole piece I I I appreciate it so
much I actually lived at the Chelsea
Hotel and when when Leonard and I first
met that was one of the first things we
talked about was the you know I lived
there where all that stuff went down
before they tore it a pot and um
yeah it's just a beautiful song you what
makes me sad the way it ends I don't
mean to suggest that I loved you the
best I can't keep track of each Fallen
Robin I remember you well in the Chelsea
Hotel that's all I don't even think of
you that often you know that line I
don't even think of you that often
always like breaks my heart for some
reason like how ephemeral how shortl
lasting like certain love affairs can be
just kind of like huh yeah do you think
he meant it I always think he doesn't
he's trying to convince himself of it it
could be both or either you know I mean
that's the beautiful thing about poetry
and lyric is that it's supposed to be
open yeah I wonder if it's also open to
him depending on the day you know
definitely I mean the thing that he
taught me um or his advice to me was
when when you're writing a
song look at it the next morning like
just first thing and read it and then
take a walk smoke a joint read it
again go have a fight with your you know
daughter come back read it again get
drunk read it again wait a week read it
again just so that you know from every
state and every position that you the
The Wider the lens is going to be from
an audience perspective you want things
to mean multiple
things uh so there's one line I read
somewhere that he regrets putting in the
song so I got to ask you about it it's
pretty edgy it's about uh giving me head
on the unmade bed yeah you think that's
a good line or bad line I think it's an
amazing line it's one of the best lines
in the song yeah right when he put that
song out obviously he didn't regret it
or he wouldn't have put that lyric in
the song I think think what happened was
that eventually word got out either from
him or from somebody else that the song
was about Janice Joplin yes and so at
that point he regretted the
indiscretion so it wasn't that he
regretted how great the line was it was
just you know the Privacy Factor but
then again Leonard's known for rewriting
his lyrics in his live shows you'll see
a bunch of songs where it's like new
lyrics MH and he didn't do it cuz he
didn't like the old lyrics he just did
it
because he could cuz he's Leonard and
it's like why not have fun with words
the way musicians have fun you know
improvising solos on stage and he could
have changed that line in Chelsea Hotel
after in retrospect and he never did I
remember you well in the Chelsea Hotel
you were talking so brave and so sweet
giving me head on the unmade bed while
The Limousines wait in the street that's
so powerful that's a it's a powerful
line it just kind of shocks you well
that's what's so so great about it mhm
yeah but also
heartbreaking cuz it doesn't last
especially actually to me it adds more
meaning once you know it's Janice Joplin
it's like okay these two stars kind of
collided for a time yeah but but what
why is it heartbreaking it could also be
just beautiful that they had a little
fling yeah everything is beautiful thank
you even the dark stuff what's not
beautiful
Everything Is Beautiful if you if you
look long enough and deeply
enough what were we saying oh uh what do
you think about Hallelujah like what
what do you think about the different
different songs of his and why did you
choose Chelsea Hotel to perform because
I lived there and it was like it meant
something to me to sing to sing that
song and uh actually when I put that
song out on YouTube that's when he sent
me an email he's like hey do you want to
you want to come over and so this is how
you guys connected no we met in a
rehearsal Studio I ended up watching
their whole rehearsal and sitting there
next to roshi his like 105y old monk
which was really great I remember when I
was like shaking his hand like like so I
like it was just me and roshi on the
couch watching Leonard with his band M
and he shaking hands and he grips my
hand like this so like doesn't let it go
and he said to my eyes he said where are
you and I said in the handshake he said
yes wow he passed the test pass the
roshi test and then what's funny was
that the next thing that happened about
five minutes later was Leonard Cohen got
down on his knees and opened up a jar
I'm not kidding you of caviar this is
not a callback well it is in a
way deep fundamental way he started
feeding the monk caviar yeah and that
healed my montro jazz festival sadness
forever the end do you think there's a
kind of like
weird like there's a sense of humor to
it all somehow like like why does that
happen why why does that
happen why like why stuff like that
happens or that the the Jeff bass speaks
to you why why do we need to know you
believe in that stuff what stuff that
there's a rhyme to the whole thing
somehow like there's a frequency to
which magical things of that nature can
happen I'm divided about that answer
because I think just things are flowing
I don't necess I don't think anything's
kind of like planned out like a through
time it's like an orchestra playing of
different experiences and circumstances
that are somehow connected I think
everything's connected so yes but
predetermined means like I don't believe
in the predetermined stuff necessarily I
which is different
from whatever your your previous karma
is and karma is a whole other kind of
conversation I don't mean karma is in
like Good Karma Bad Karma just karma
meaning the collection of things you
have acquired over this lifetime or
lifetimes just whatever that whatever
that is is going to influence your
future MH so well you had a really
interesting trajectory through
life uh maybe I just read it that way
because I've had a lot of stuff happen
to me that's like lucky feels lucky and
sometimes I wonder like huh like this is
weird it does feel like the universe
just kind of throw stuff at you with a
chuckle I don't know not you the proverb
you
one